so the first thing I'm going to put on
here and I'll admit it's easier to see
on here sorry I tried to make the
photocopy as dark as I could so you can
see the in-between lines but I'm gonna
put on y equals one right that's
important so here I think is where I
should have y equals one there we go
yeah it's cheating I know sorry now
there's like was one okay
there's also a part that I'm gonna
highlight so that I can ignore it what
pie is that yeah just this guy in here
just little strip between negative three
and negative two okay can I just make
sure I've got everyone's attention just
pens out of your heads for a second to
look up just so I make sure that I'm not
losing anyone okay now I've got this
part that I'm gonna ignore I've got this
y equals one should have labeled that
I've got this y equals one in order to
help me work out some important points
and I'm gonna start to think about what
they are right now firstly I'm gonna
look for where the original graph has y
equals zero what X values will give me y
equals zero R hacen okay minus two is
here and minus three is here now in the
previous question I asked you to go
ahead and draw some fat blobs here
rather than crosses like I did anywhere
else right
as you know one worked out why I did
that anyone Ian what do you think ah so
you notice right because the intercepts
right and we've told ourselves to ignore
this part down here the graph stops it
doesn't keep on going right now we want
to know when you're graphing this right
just like when you're doing an
inequality on the number line if you
were doing a number line like this and I
wanted you to say okay here is an
inequality like this and that's three or
something like that right I need to know
can I equal three or not that's
important information to me and you
would either put a hollow circle or you
would put a filled circle now in this
case here I've asked you to put in a
filled circle why is that why isn't it
hollow Gary
yeah that's right I'm allowed to go
there aren't I the square root of zero
you can totally take the squared as
Europe it's zero right and it's the same
deal here and any other time your
original graph is zero you can exist it
okay very good
what were the other two important points
yeah yeah it's gonna go right all the
way I can see this point here and also
this point here where I intersect with
wake was one right so what's the square
root of one it's just one so I'm going
through there
and there what are the values did you
see that we useful I can see a couple of
spots where I've got y equals four now
just be careful here it's harder to see
on your printout but that doesn't line
up with here it's just a little bit to
the side so I'm gonna draw carefully
from there and then I've got a cross
right there did I do that right yep
that's one that's two you with me same
deal over here is this starting to look
familiar our original function s
symmetry so when we take the square root
of it it's also gonna have symmetry
right it's the same thing on both sides
right all right was there any other
values you could see that we useful you
could probably nude shoe but that's a
bit hard to do I mean I I would like
some nice values if I can and I go high
enough what do you see I see nine I
think I heard the wire did you say it as
well yep so if I take the square root of
nine which is all the way up here what
should that come down to on my new
function should come down to three very
good like so and it's the same thing
over here
okay whoops I've gone too far
sorry there we go all right I want to do
one last pair of points do you remember
last time I looked for where a quarter
was do remember that why was a quarter a
useful point for me because the square
of a quarter and I'm taking square roots
of everything is a half it's a nice easy
spot to find so where am i equal to a
quarter
it looks to me like the original graph
is a quarter about there do you remember
that
so my new graph is going to be just
above that at a half right there and
it's the same deal over on the other
side I'm gonna be just above well that's
heavy okay except it's kind of sunny
everything which is weird look anyone's
yes sort of all right are you ready to
go ready to draw this thing okay now can
I actually for this part eyes up for me
two pens down because what I'm gonna
draw is probably similar to what you've
got it'll be different you're asking
about these two right so on the original
graph here the original graph is a
quarter my graph is going to be the
square root of that which is a half okay
all right here's my best shot here's
what I got
okay now can ask you to put your pants
down and look up for a second
and compare thanks mo compare what
you've got with what I have got okay
now maybe you thought oh I did the
previous one right and we got this
sideways parabola ish looking thin right
you're like the points that I'm plotting
on this new one looks suspiciously
similar to that right so you look and
you're like yeah it looks like it's
doing that thing but you might notice
can you take a ruler take a ruler and
put it against where you've got these
values here all right now if you place a
ruler on those three axes you should
notice it's pretty much bang on a
straight line okay you can even measure
right there's like this rise over run
and it's consistent okay there's only
one little pile by the way same thing
over here right same thing over here
there's only one little bit that bucks
that trend it's just just this teeny
behead you know is that it's like
there's some weird quantum weirdness
going on there but everything else
you're getting a straight line now why
should that be exactly what you expect x
squared right there if you square roots
it get rid of this way very good now I
want to repeat what Zaki just said
because it's so helpful right what we
started with was a parabola which is of
the kind x squared right so when you
take the square root whoops of something
like x squared right in fact if you
think back that should be where the
definition for this this is actually the
absolute value of x remember that look
at this thing here right do you see how
much this looks like that weird bouncy V
shape right it isn't exactly the same
because what I've got here is not
exactly x squared is it it is in fact
this is x squared plus 5x plus 6 so this
bit on the end accounts for it's
slightly different it's slightly
different but if you went to desmos and
you put in y equals in fact if you went
to desmos if you when you go to desmos
if you put in x squared let's call that
guy f of X
right what am I done equals there it is
right and now if you say let's do the
square root of f of X does that look
familiar
right sorry let me make that a little
easier to see right so that's what we're
getting basically but in this case
because we're off a little bit in here
it's a little bit sneaky okay no I won't
make a parallel come back to it do you
have that page there where you did
squaring do you have it yep here's a
good example okay so this is what we did
the squaring right now you knew how I
drew the y equals one in the y equals
negative one right and in here what
happened was if you square these small
values they get smaller did you notice
that see there's a small value in this
one smaller
here's a small value this one's smaller
and if you square a big value it gets
bigger right big value gets bigger big
value gets bigger right what we're doing
right now is the exact opposite of that
yeah we are doing mm-hmm have a look at
this guy now right yet see any small
values they get a little bigger
see these big values they get smaller
because the square it's the exact
opposite okay